Primero considera la expresión para,
-5 más la cantidad de 4 veces "x".
Ahora, toma el producto de -8 y esa expresión,
y entonces suma 6.
Hagamos esto paso a paso,
primero vamos a tener esta expresión.
-5 más algo, tenemos para empezar -5 más
la cantidad de 4 veces "x"...
la cantidad de 4 veces "x", que a a ser simplemente "4x".
-5 más "4x".
Esa es esta primer a expresión.
Ahora, toma el producto de -8...
el producto de -8...
-8 que multiplica a esta expresión...
el producto de -8 y esa expresión...
vamos a marcarla aquí...
esa expresión que es -5 más "4x",
si ahora tomamos el producto de -8 y esa expresión,
esto va a ser -8 que multiplica a -5
más "4x", ésta es -8,
éste es esa expresión, el producto...
el producto de esos dos, podemos poner el
signo de multiplicación ahí o dejarlo indicado
implícitamente, toma el producto de -8 y
esa expresión y entonces súmale 6...
y entonces súmale 6, es decir,
a todo eso le vamos a sumar 6...
más 6...
Todo esto lo podemos indicar como -8,
se abre el paréntesis, -5 más "4x" y finalmente más 6.
Hagamos uno más.
Primero considera la expresión,
la suma de 7...
la suma de 7 y eso va a ser 7 más,
el producto de -2 y "x"...
el producto de -2 y "x", esto va a ser "-2x",
7 más "-2x", esa es la primera expresión,
lo cual podemos escribir también como,
esto es exactamente igual a 7 menos "2x",
estas dos son equivalentes.
¿Qué expresión será, 4 más... 4 más...
la cantidad de 2 veces esa expresión?
Esa cantidad que vamos a sumar, vamos a indicarla
aquí entre paréntesis, la cantidad de 2 veces...
la cantidad de 2 veces, lo voy a poner en amarillo...
la cantidad de 2 por esa expresión...
esa expresión... vamos a ponerla en azul,
esta expresión que tenemos aquí,
así es que la cantidad que vamos a sumar, va a ser dos veces esa expresión que es 7 menos "2x".
Y así hemos concluido.